Speaker 1: I want to do a short update on a
story we did yesterday. Yesterday, I told you
that Lizelle Herrera has been charged with
murder for a quote, self-induced abortion.
Those charges have now been dropped, and
the entire story is getting even more,
more strange. So Newsweek reporting abortion
murder charge against Texas woman Spurs calls
for a hippo lawsuit an actual hippo lawsuit.
Not like someone asks Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Are you vaccinated? And she goes, That's my
HIPA. No, Marjorie, it's not. The article says
officers arrested the 26 year old on charges of
intentionally and knowingly causing the abortion,
sparking international backlash
against Texas abortion restrictions.
She miscarried at a hospital and allegedly
confided to hospital staff that she attempted
to induce her own abortion, and she was
reported to the authorities by hospital staff.
Starr County District Attorney said Sunday he
would drop charges against Herrera. But the
incident led some critics of Texas abortion policy
to argue the arrest stemmed from a HIPA violation,
meaning that medical professionals disclosed
patient information and they are suggesting
that she sue. So there's two different things
here. First of all, she was she was charged
and we said, What the hell are they thinking?
And then as soon as it became national news,
they say there was no criminal act. We're dropping
the charges. This is the office that indicted her
in the first place. So what were they doing?
Were they testing the waters to see what they
could get away with? Will they do it next time?
And maybe there won't be a public outcry and then
you actually go through with the prosecution of
a woman for abortion? What is it that they're
trying to do? Are they trying to instill a sort of
chilling effect on women in Texas about, listen,
you could get arrested if you get an abortion?
We don't know. OK, that's one side of it. And
then the other side of it is, was it a hipa
violation for the hospital to call the police?
There is a HIPA exception for if you suspect
someone committed a crime in good faith. And
how do you how do you know if it's in good
faith, if you, as a medical provider, suspect
someone committed a crime? There are exceptions
to HIPA. They are very narrow and you have to,
if I understand correctly, believe the crime was
committed on the premises, meaning the hospital
or wherever there. There's no indication
that the attempt at a self-induced abortion
took place at the hospital. And thus, as much
as I understand that this would not qualify for
that HIPA exemption, it has to be investigated.
But also remember that abortion is not a crime.
So the entire thing is a mess. It should be looked
into whether there was a HIPA violation, but the
good news is, at least in this case, charges
were dropped, although we can speculate about
what the broader goal was of bringing charges in
the first place. We'll have more on this on our
Instagram at David Pakman show. And I hope to hear
from you. What do you think the goal was here?